meet rep back Oh Stu pasta yeah we know  it won't eat these birds will feast on  your guts here alone pork soldier  destined for death now what would you  know that all these others dead or stem  can teach you the ways of the arc baby  you call this a duel yeah I call this  losing it do ya glob but with a little  help from you he'd better hurry or he  lose his hand  hopefully tempting is not at all he may  be useful what's the war chief here's my  victory he'll make me personal bodyguard  and how does this help you do a  backstabbing bodyguard you make sure you  keep your head a little back this time  yeah well that's my plan yeah you can  take him from an orc that's nibbles and  whines make sure you show up to take the  place of the Dead Oh cheer up  but the war Chiefs not dead going to  cotillion oh good plan to a mighty war  chief that's nibbles and whines I just  thought that  you